hello and welcome to my tutorial on
encryption with python someone made this
uh request for this video so i went
ahead and made it
uh it's going to be a little bit longer
than most of the videos by a little bit
i mean a lot of it
simply because there's a lot of
information to pass on with this
um and i can't really make it in chunks
because it's kind of needs to be all
together so
if you don't like long tutorials i'm
sorry
encryption isn't going to be for you
anyway so to start we're going to need
some sort of encryption software because
you're not going to encrypt yourself
it's pretty complex stuff
so you'll want to get at least some sort
of import
for encrypting so you'll want to go this
is the website for pi crypto which is
probably the most popular encryption
tool with python
i would just download the latest version
you just click here and you'll download
the tarball
if you don't have
i'm not really talk too much about this
if you don't have anything
to extract the tarball with you can use
this program called 7-zip it's like
7-zip or something like that and that'll
get the files out and if you don't know
how to
actually open up the
or install the file it's usually pretty
easy
let me open up a command prompt
hello i'm going to go ahead and
re-record this i just noticed in the
video that my command prompt is probably
one of the worst colors possible for
seeing what's actually being said so
we'll just change it here so when you
open up the command prompt now again
this is a command prompt not the python
interpreter
let's say you've got the file on your
desktop you'll use cd for change
directory and you'll choose desktop like
it it's basically change directory into
something that you're already in but you
can type out like the full directory too
if you want but anyway that's just uh
command prompt lingo so now that you're
on desktop um
i've got pi crypto on my desktop so i'm
going to say cd into pi
crypto i've got like it's like a file
folder basically for pi crypto
uh what did i do wrong
oh we didn't have the y there
i
pi
krypto
there we go and so once you're in the pi
crypto
folder uh you should see like a bunch of
stuff in that folder like this is the
folder here you've got billable all this
stuff and if you scroll down here's a
setup.py that's the file that will
basically set up
um whatever install that you want to do
and so the way that you do that is you
just you type in python setup
setup.py and then install now i've
already installed it myself so i'm not
going to do it but then you would just
hit enter here and that will uh install
pi crypto and really other any other
import that has uh setup.py in it
once you've got it installed and
downloaded from here
um
generally you're gonna well first i'll
teach you how to do it but most you know
if you're encrypting something it's
because you're transferring it or you're
maybe storing it for yourself or
something but encryption and decryption
kind of go together
um
and so i'm gonna have to show you them
both and what i'm gonna do is just kind
of split them up and i'll have an
encryption file over here and then a
decryption file over here that way you
can kind of understand what's going on
so to start off uh once you have uh pi
crypto uh set up properly you'll need to
do this import you'll do from or from
crypto
import aes
now
there are various forms of encryption
aes is just kind of one of the many
forms
and generally
there's two different types of
i guess encryption processes there's
symmetric
key algorithms and this is where you
have the same key for encryption
decryption which is what aes has
and then there's also asymmetric key
algorithms where you have one key
for encrypting and then one key for
decrypting
uh generally the more accepted version
of encryption is indeed aes and you want
128
bit encryption just for the record we'll
talk about that that in just a moment as
we get to it but yeah aes is probably
the most popular form of encryption
anyways
um so that's what we're going to use
uh the next import that you're going to
need is
base 64. and what base64 is used for is
actually encoding and you don't want to
get that confused with encryption
they're two very different things
basically encodings for putting data in
a specific format
um
so it can be recognized by it's kind of
like you know you convert something to a
string or something like it needs to be
in a specific format to be read by
something that's what base64 is doing
it's encoding it kind of like encoding a
url so it can be recognized it's the
same stuff
um so you'll need base64 for encoding
and then um the third and final import
that we're going to need is import os
and the reason for os and what we want
in os for is for the function called you
random
which is kind of an accepted producer of
randomness that's suitable for
cryptology
simple random
isn't really as it is accepted i mean
you can use it but
people prefer you random over that
so moving right along now we're going to
define our encryption function
so say encryption and then within here
we're going to do we'll just say our
variable or
parameter rather is going to be private
info
and so the first thing that we want to
specify is
block
size
size
and
basically you can choose between 16 24
and 32 for aes and that's going to
correspond to bits like these are bytes
and then it corresponds to bits so
you could do 32 bytes for 256 bit
encryption or you can do 16 bit or 16
bytes for 128 bits
and so on so we're going to do 16 bit
or 16 bytes for 128 bit encryption which
is the accepted um just as an aside if
you're if you're trying to learn how to
do encryption because you accept maybe
like people's credit card information
online or something like that you're
kind of like obligated
to encrypt their data and the
basic uh
i'm trying to think like the widely
except the one that the us government
backs is 128-bit aes encryption so
that's what i suggest you use if you're
liable for any of the information that
you're storing but also the reason they
support it is because it's good
um just another
side basically a
you can go as low as like a 32-bit
encryption and
basically with today's computational
power a decent computer would have that
key just by brute force techniques only
they could have that key correct in
probably like less than an hour so
32-bit keys are not very protective at
all
um the 64-bit key is getting closer
uh it would take probably like a few
months with a decent computer and that's
only if you know for if you ran through
all 100 percent of the combinations
like if you if you don't have
like it's highly highly likely that
you're not going to run through a
hundred percent of the combinations
before you find the correct one
but anyway with 128 bit this considered
pretty safe at the moment just because
it would just take like centuries
with a bunch of computers to crack it
but obviously over time as processors
get better and better you're going to
need better encryption
so anyways moving right along after
block size the next thing you have to
define is padding
um this is the only thing that really
confuses me uh it's like some sort of
algorithm that you can use but you can
put like anything in here like you can
put like 999 and all this kind of stuff
like apparently like this open curly
braces is like some sort of algorithm
um if you understand that let me know i
don't really understand it myself i just
know that that's what people do so
that's what i'm doing
um
and i guess the reason you use uh
padding at all is so it's for sure like
whatever your um the values that you
encrypt are multiple of the block size
and length
so this is just like use some sort of
padding to ensure that that is the case
so it can actually be like understood
and decrypted later on
um
so now the next thing is
um
if i just pad
and to do this we're going to call
lambda
and
our parameter for lambda will just be c
right i'm sorry
lambda our parameter will be s
and then we're going to say s plus
block size
minus the length of s
and then
block size
block size
times
padding
so what's happening here is we're
actually we're like um
we're actually like gonna pat this is
the process to actually pad
the data with our padding up here um
just as a quick aside let me show you
what lambda is since if you're not
familiar with lambda
you might not understand how this works
um so i've just brought up a command
prompt here
oops actually let's close that out i
just need to have python up so if you're
not familiar with lambda
let me just show you how lambda really
works it's kind of like a really really
quick way to embed a function in a
function and it's like a one-liner
function it's it's just really easy to
do it
so or really like a function and a
variable anyway
so just as a quick example let's say we
want to define our variable as addition
equals and then lambda and this
basically like lambda is like notifying
python that we're about to do this
really weird thing
um and then kind of like a function you
have to define what your parameters are
but there's no parentheses so you do
like lambda x and then just like at the
end of a function you have to have a
colon
and then
um you specify what you how you want
that function to work so we're just
gonna say x plus five
okay
so
hit enter and now that's been defined so
now what you can do is you can say
addition
and
uh we'll do three so it should give us
eight
and sure enough it gave us eight
and that's all thanks to this lambda
now the reason why it's actually used in
encryption
is it kinda it's it's used for
abstraction of functions
um
so that's really the reason why you're
using it within incre with with
encryption basically so moving right
along now
we're going to define how we want this
to be encoded and so you're going to
just we'll call this code aes equals and
then we'll hit hit up lambda again c and
then as
basically to
correspond here
um
we want to call base64
and again this is basic c4 is for
encoding dot b
64. i want to say
code and then
so that's what you're actually going to
encode and then you want to encode
whatever you know the c variable is
uh or c parameter rather
c dot
encrypt then we want to encrypt the
padded version
of
this s
variable basically your best parameter
and
close that again
and one more time
and i want to say okay yeah so we're
done there now what we need to do is
every basically every encryption has a
key and so now we need to generate this
key so we're going to call the key
secret
and that's going to be equals os you
random
which is why we imported os up here
you random and then you have um
block size here block
size
and then just so we can actually see it
we'll want to say you know print
encryption key
and secret
and now what we need to do is establish
a cipher object basically um so to do
that you're gonna need cipher equals aes
dot new and then secret
i think we've added a space here
and then finally we encode whatever our
string is going to be so
encoded
we'll call it equals and code aes which
is talking about here
and now
um
our two variables because our encode aes
is lambda c comma s so there's two
parameters that we're given here so now
you have to specify the two parameters
that you want so you've got cipher
and then private info
and as you can see what it's going to do
now is it's going to do cipher it's
going to encrypt the cipher and then use
for basically
it's going to take the cipher encrypt
with the padded version of s
this is the basic
easiest way i can say that which wasn't
very easy
and then finally you can print out
encrypted
strings on
comma
and then encoded
and now we have hopefully explained to
you how encryption works and now let's
see what it looks like for us
and we'll call encryption
encrypt
and then inside here is where we're
going to put a secret message
that is very sensitive
and you want no one to read it
even the government
hit enter and as you can see here is our
encryption key and then this is the
actual encrypted info
now just as an aside what you can do
later on is you could just say cipher
equals
and then
um
oh we misspelled the string that's going
to bother me anyway you could say secret
i'm sorry not cipher you could say
secret equals
so instead of generating a new one this
is how you would generate a new
key but instead of doing that like say
you've already established a key that
you like and you've maybe memorized for
yourself you would just put this within
there and then you're obviously like
this is not a ci coding which so you'll
have to have something up there
um but i'll show you that in just a
second because we're gonna need it for
the decryption anyways
uh okay so
um let's run this one more time since
something went awry there
actually let me close it so we don't get
confused
so again uh encryption
private information that you
do not want the government
to see
close it
okay and then here's our new encryption
key because again we generated a new one
but again
you can't just generate new encryption
keys every time you need to generate
just one if you're sending the data
across somewhere you're going to need
just one encryption key and so like both
sources are going to need to know it
so anyway now over in decryption how do
we actually decrypt
this stuff
now that we have the key anyways
so same imports as before i'm just going
to copy and paste them over
and now we need to define
decryption
and then within the parentheses we'll
just say our parameters encrypted
string
colon
padding
we're going to say the exact same
padding i'm pretty sure you're going to
have to keep that same
now we define decode
decode a yes
and then we have our lambda function
lambda
c comma e
and we're going to do c dot decrypt
using base64
dot b64
decode because we're going to have to
decode
the encode
of this information and then obviously
the variable in there is going to be
and we're going to be stripping away the
padding that we added before
so
padding
um now our encryption
um
i'm not sure why i've done this
encrypted string let's see i guess what
i would want to do is just we'll say the
key equals and we'll define our key now
which is
this
and once we run it it's going to tell me
i've got some funky coding and what to
put up here i don't really know what to
put up there just yet so we'll wait till
we get to that point
um
because this is clearly non-asci
characters
so the next thing we want is cipher
equals
as.new
and we're going to want to use the key
that we had before
for the cipher
and
decoded then is going to equal
the code a s
so obviously we're referencing up here
cipher using that cipher that we've just
said and then
we want to use it on
the encrypted string
close
and then finally print decoded
so hopefully we've not spelled anything
wrong yeah sure okay so we need to add
this to the top of the file hit ok but
if you also just hit edit my file it'll
go right up there for you
so we'll use that save it we'll run it
we'll bring it over here
and then what we'll do
we'll take this information here and
we'll say
decryption
now we've already put this key into here
because this the python shell isn't
going to automatic like you would have
to have this coding in there beforehand
but what you could do
is instead of saving the key in here
since we already know it's going to be
cp 1252 i'll show you guys in a second
that you could take key out and then put
it in this parameters here
because obviously you're not going to
want the key to be in your script like
you don't want to save the key anywhere
so anyway
um i guess you could have the key in
there but generally you probably
wouldn't want to if you wanted to be
super safe
um you would prob you'd probably want to
be pulling the key from another file
that possibly encrypted itself
um
what's that in oh encrypted string so we
just need to slap this misspelled
encrypted string
right on in there
hit enter and sure enough it decrypts it
into private information that you do not
want the government to see
and that's really it that's all you have
to do to do encryption um
so anyway i hope you guys enjoyed hope
you maybe learned something and until
next time